[Musique]
bienvenue à l'express depuis 40 ans ce
resto propose des classiques de la
cuisine française
c'est quoi un foie de veau classique
bain ici c'est avec la sauce à
l'estragon
voici le chef jean-françois d'achon ya
toute une génération élevée avec une
fois de gros en rouler dans la farine
souvent très durs et très mince ce qui
fait que beaucoup de gens maintenant
qu'ils viennent même toit mettez vous
faites c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
quelque chose dans la fête qui répondent
aux goûts ferreux
c'est ça plaît pas à tout le monde et
puis bon crs1 abba aussi peut-être au
niveau mental faire abstraction annaba
exemple de toxines comme nous le précise
l'afutt dix scientifiques
anne-marie des billets le fois c'est un
peu une usine de transformation c'est un
peu une usine qui déconstruit les
toxines et pas qu'ils emmagasinent
contrairement à la croyance populaire
que la foi peut être corrigé de toxines
et qu'il faut le détoxifiant sans
toxines peu gras le foie de veau et de
plus riches en fer mais aussi en
vitamine a et b voulez mais comme un
retraitement rose et même met en scène
un médecin
mais cette cuisson n'est pas sans risque
question de bien apprécier ce débat il
faut savoir le faire cuire correctement
sont faits en tranches
je le fais pour une femme une minute et
demie du premier côté il fait ensuite
quand je le tourne je fais juste fermer
mon rond depuis le laisser
tranquillement finir dans le dans le
beurre mousseux et puis fini tu es tout
seul et c'est ici qu'on se doit
d'insister il faut bien faire cuire le
foie de veau les consommateurs en
général pas vraiment connaissance doit
avoir des risques avec les abords on
sait avec la viande crue on savait que
tartare avec des hamburgers 80 jeunes
du boeuf haché mais
le football s'est passé pas très très
connus ont fait ce test de puissants
allons-y aghmari nous rappelle les
dangers de manger un foie de veau poser
c'est cuit il ya plusieurs études qui
démontrent en route une du mapaq faye
ont révélé que 28 % des échantillons de
foie de veau qui ont analysés
contenaient la bactérie campylobacter ça
peut occasionner maux de ventre
diarrhées nausées et vomissements
particulièrement chez les personnes au
système immunitaire faible contrairement
à la gastro qui est d'origine virale qui
peuvent facilement se propager
notre toute la famille la
gastro-entérite bactérienne qui est
causé par campylobacter et elles vont
continuer sa main la personne qui a
mangé l'aliment qui contamine est
question de tuer cette bactérie il faut
atteindre une température de 63 degrés
celsius au centre du foie de veau bon
alors le jeu fait quoi si j'aime pas le
foie de veau bien là pas grand chose à
faire est malheureusement pas ce que les
risques qui a des micro-organismes à
l'intérieur est vraiment très présente
de par la nature du foie oui ça continue
comme non je n'ai pas cinq hockeyeurs de
l'espoir ça faisait que j'aurais pu le
sortir plus rapidement mais si vous
préférez le foie de veau plus épais en
pv il faut prévoir une cuisson plus
longue pour moi c'est une élection voire
même lumineux
et puis faut calculer un petit camp de
recours pour que la chaleur est
tranquillement vers l'intérieur
on voit qu'on commence à remonter les
colorations on fallait quatre tasses
comme ça en ce moment si je baisse mon
que presque au minimum pour juste finir
de le ville d'origine science fait le
poids devant super bowl voilà maintenant
cinq semaines dans plusieurs livres de
recettes
on propose de faire tremper le foie de
veau dans le lait je pense qu'à l'époque
il faisait ça pour enlever un peu
l'amertume est ce que ça aide ou pas de
faire 30 et préalablement le foie dans
le nez j'ai pas trouvé d'explication
scientifique ou défaire réel que cette
technique club pourrait avoir sur le
foie de veau nous avons demandé à notre
chef de faire une cuisson avec et sans
trempage dans le legs alors celui là est
avec avec le lait
un très bon maintenant je sais
l express classique n'est pas vraiment
différent
pas vraiment peut-être moi je préfère
celui là
alors on oublie d'être avantage mais ça
c'est le foot est caramélisée et lola
vous êtes content avec les chefs
où
[Musique]